ciao a tutti mi terrorizza se otteniamo
fare lo slime sott'acqua
secondo voi sia o non sia scrivete
lavora nei commenti vediamo chi indovina
e mi raccomando lasciato un bel live che
se volete vedere altri esperimenti pazzi
con lo sly non fatevi pure sa bene i
commenti che sperimenti volesse vedere
con i flame
o con altre cose scrivetemi pure le
vostre idee e ora siete pronti proviamo
a fare questo saremo sott'acqua è strano
parlarsi d'acqua stato vero però è anche
devastante questo blueberry abbiamo
subito e vediamo un po come se so che i
ragazzi iniziano subito con la colla per
fanno ancora felicissimo è deciso di
fare la colla trasparente vediamo se
riusciamo a vederla sott'acqua sono
accordate trasparentemente bisogna
vederla vediamo un po se vuoi che
cercare di centrare un ascolto no magari
non si dissolve
che si è risolta
spero che cada accadendo la ciotola sì
un po mento volta per un pacco rendono
la ciotola tra vi propone terme altra a
che fa staccare non fuori però conti
dovrebbe bastare
vedete un po opaca per questo è un po di
curling qua
speriamo di riuscirci allora ora vado a
mettere delle decorazioni stavo pensando
di mettere il colorante ma se metto il
colorante va a colorare tutta l'acqua
non penso che colori uno strike quindi
troviamo con un po di decorazioni allora
a metterle conchigliette così siamo a
tema
peccato mi ha un po perché queste
galletti in realtà perché non giocante
queste rho corriamo presenti o che non
cadendo nella colla vedevo incastrare
dentro gobbi per la sfigata faremo
slides vento l'acqua grazie tante sotto
l'acqua l'istituto l'acqua sono riuscite
mai per l'elettro è stranissimo alla
colla questa che sembra leggerissimo
strano e per il resto tutti i filamenti
e poi un'altra coniglietta di qua ok
altrimenti questo viste fino ad
attivarlo ottenuto con il bicarbonato
come fa è unito che si scioglie con
l'acqua abbiamo fatto troppo divertente
bellissimo
magari se questo video raggiungi 10.000
l'ice proverò a fare anche nucleco la
colla bianca sott'acqua fatemi sapere se
vi interessa vederlo voglio mettere
anche questi clipper bellissimi sono
viola sono delle stelline che si dà che
vediamo prima strada o per questo ci ha
detto colpo sta scendendo a forse sarà
molto più difficile pretendere effetti
sono piccolissimi proviamo staccando
noi dopo strano di perle al collo su pc
sembra già creata perché non sempre
liquida non si incolla che i ragazzi
cos'altro potremmo oddio non ho visto
che il pieno di stelle e qua sopra o
riuscito a mettere però la maggior parte
almeno penso al preso cadute per terra
non può non riesco a recuperare tutto il
suo libro più piccole
allora ho deciso di provare lo stesso
utilizzare il colorante voglio riuscire
a colorarlo anche se c'è il rischio che
si colori l'acqua il problema è che
scelto il giallo e poi mai fatto se sì
con una hd giallo non è molto bello pero
aiutante no quindi devono fare anche
anche attento per questo la codeina
inventò lo diventa schifosissimo ma
perché non silvered che ridere guarda
anche sui giornali di attenzione certo
ma approviamo non so se no non posso
marzo
si ripeta quindi devo ammetterlo d'acqua
[Musica]
basta questa scendere io non sta
immobile così l'acqua non si sposta
esatto si fa cenno ma è bellissimo
un'altra goccia e adesso perché come
però una mano nell'acqua si diffonderà
gli arresti dell'acqua quindi aspettiamo
che scenda un po nello slang poiché
stanno salendo delle decorazioni per
scappato senza ridere seguire tappate
oggi è stranissimo wow alto possiamo
aggiungere un idea
mettiamo la neve finta però con la mega
hit si espande già mettendo la
nell'acqua è quindi che ci proviamo ad
attivarlo qualcos'altro attivare andiamo
anche perché giallo è uscito fuori dalla
ciò che io non so come faremo per la
soluzione per letti non penso che ci
siano problemi
penso che andrà bene dentro peccati
bicarbonato di sodio perché sole note
tropea
ma vediamo non vedo di essere ascoltato
già lo faccio un buco e sto fatto un
buco dietro roseline per il bicarbonato
mi è venuto un idea ne metto un po in
mano o il bicarbonato lo stringo bene in
modo così magari non si scioglie e
mentre mettono mano dentro
proviamo
e strano un pannello tutta l'europa e
che il giallo dovresti provare poi fa
ciotola machete male poi la pa nella
ciotola
ok allora nel frattempo l'acqua è
diventata non perde poco invitante
perché il blu con il giallo
e quanto cercando di recuperare mo il
flying banche perché la cosa si fa
troppo quindi per presi con la calabria
adesso è meglio che stia succedendo
qualcosa siamo un po di soluzione
talenti
vediamo ma immaginate se adesso tutta la
vaschetta diventa uno slide super cicli
slam ho visto che c'è la folla ci sono
vaschetta se continuano team hanno
bambini diventano soccorsi gri veramente
poiché nera si scusa con la bolla
trasparente è possibile penso non lo so
proviamo con la colla bianca speriamo
che funzioni
guidiamo tante tante tutte queste cose
non le vedevamo con la colla trasparente
perché trasparente ma che strada gente
positano
tutto togliendo le sponde oddio fumo
accingiamo a sti fattore così a casa
magari esce un super cicli slime zio ma
in cui ho tutta la fisi ha con la bianca
è rovinato tutto adesso sembra uno
stagno slam antico allora l'ultima
opzione essere questo ben poco
vediamo se cs comunque lo slime essendo
lo fa dentro allora siccome non è un
sito lo serve sotto l'acqua
ho preso un bel po di acqua di qua in
più aggiunto la colla e ora sto
mischiando così faccio un bel tigris
live da quest'acqua qui almeno uno slide
si s penso che sia super g b lì visto
che c'era un sacco di acqua dentro e
quindi siete curiosi di vedere il
risultato è quasi pronto che si utilizza
i ragazzi
fortunatamente questo è lecito perché
almeno mi rimane un slime e motocicli
guardate dovrà a questo sentire i rumori
che viene da te quanto tremola vino
ovviamente la consistenza input rana
perché quella quali e come è stato
attivato è un po strano però sono
comunque contenta che uno zaino piero
uscito e non mi aspettavo che lo tiene
sott'acqua sarebbe stato così difficili
da fare allora fatevi pure sapere miei
commenti con gli altri esperimenti pozzi
volete che facciamo assieme perché
questo video vi sia piaciuto la società
ben like e ora vi lascio fa 4 quadratini
su cui cliccare a prevedere i prossimi
video chat video divertenti cliccato su
quello che preferite e buona visione
ciao